We can just filter the image, right?
So we filter the image, tada.
Yuck.
All right.
You know, the first thing
that happens is you realize
you've got all of these white pixels.
Why is that?
Well, because they didn't have
a huge amount of V but they,
they still had, a reasonable
amount of that Y, all right?
So how would filter out
these bright pixels?
Well duh, you would just reduce
the requirement on the luminance,
we're not going to allow all
of the Y pixels anymore.
Instead, we'll filter,
we might say, well,
we're going to allow the luminance of
just, I don't know, 0 to 150, let's say.
And so that would eliminate, so
here we are in the same, right?
That, so
that would capture all of these pixels.
All right?
So now if we use that, right?
We in,
we include the Y value of 0 to 150,
we get a much better
selection of the red pixels.
And this is just to show you comparison
that it's just easier to do this on the,
in the YUV space than the RGB space.
The only reason this is easier
is because we're using boxes.
Right.
Because there's a linear combination of
RGB that will give you almost prelim,
it'll give you YUV.
If you could orient your boxes they
would end being the same filter, but
if your trying to limit the boxes
they would be straightforward.